ae
boa noite obrigado pela oportunidade de
estar aqui falando sobre esse projeto é
o seguinte nenhuma e eu queria perguntar
vocês sentem o skate sabe amanhã mas
para vocês entenderem sobre o animal
sobre o clima do skate anima contar uma
historinha sobre minha infância eu
fiquei lá pelos 10 e 11 anos de idade e
não foi meu pai que me dão skate no
primeiro skate pro meu irmão que me deu
de futebol da bola
das quatro linhas e eu me apaixonei por
essa maneira que de manhã em chegar de
todas e melhor qualidade de vida
muitos amigos
a cidade é aquela época não tinha pista
o que esperava mesmo era arriscada o
irmão cordão da calçada isso que a gente
sobre o estatuto da cidade que a gente
usava pra fazer o nome do skate
eu já fui já foi preso não eu já fui na
delegacia simplesmente andar de skate
o presidente do coletivo por um ano
brincadeira mas é verdade que não é
crime mas nós já fosse e lagoa dos 13
anos em 1993 tinha competir em um
campeonato de skate tinha um repórter
nele extraído eu acho que ele estava
acostumado com o futebol
ele achou que eu tinha vencido mas não
tinha um cara segundo lugar
daí ele veio me entrevistar vem aquela
pergunta o que quer ser quando crescer
puxa pergunta tão óbvia além disso a
resposta eu respondi o que ele queria
ouvir ali mas crescer crescer 13 anos é
coletar preocupar com isso né
ele é na escrita de a todo me divertir e
é isso que me deixa feliz
o movimento foi expressar a liberdade da
energia toda e mas agora falando crescer
nessa pressão já não possa criar a
certeza
o lecce ontem tac define os petistas de
uma maneira mais sagaz entregue à vista
ele fala os petistas é um cara que
nasceu para ser uma futura vida inteira
é a que fala nessa perspectiva não traz
nenhuma assinatura inteiro mas aí ele
utilizará imaturo não é responsável ele
aponta que tem coisas diferentes aí o 30
feridos e eu queremos dizer que também
aquele objectivo é um cara que tem
espírito jovem é aquela alegria no
coração vai fazer disso vai tocar a vida
dele
dessa maneira não importa o que aconteça
a gente vai tocar essa alegria do
espírito e acho que ele vai ea vida
o mário sérgio cortella conhecer aqui
refletiu sobre ela colhia ambiente e
atuar sobre o riso desencana mulher do
envelhecimento espírito comum é a falta
de dar um sentido na vida aquela energia
vital e dá sentido e fortalece nossa
vida nosso projeto de vida
então ele fala pra gente sempre tinha o
phelps além do agente recomeçar pra
gente se apaixonava o nosso projeto de
vida e sempre recomeçar e transbordar
na fisioterapia eu sempre quis que a
evolução alcançada no neutro das quatro
linhas da clínica refletisse para a vida
real do paciente não me bastava o
movimento ele apresentasse ali é um
exercício que ele tivesse conseguido mas
eu tinha o desejo de dentro da casa dele
ou dentro da vida dele no ambiente
escolar onde fosse
isso é refletido de verdade em uma
sessão de fisioterapia na m
a paciente tinha com paralisia cerebral
com o rendimento do motor bem importante
assim os quatro membros macaé trabalho
sipat
ela sabia que eu tinha skate não andava
de skate e ela pediu mais tempo pode
trazer na próxima sessão de skate e ela
com um problema na articulação da fala
se será que eu tô sendo investido pelo
meu rosto está falando isso mesmo
confirmou o incidente e fiquei muito
feliz com isso na sessão seguinte estava
lá eu
foi um desafio à memória pra mim e
agente orientador causava pequeno de
macho a gente conseguiu adaptar eu usei
quando ela acha da fisioterapia assim
prometeu o esquerdino perto nos
queixamos cavar o skate não se apaga o
jogador também aí a gente foi pra rampa
de acesso da instituição e a gente
mereceu essa foi a previsão é enorme
nosso foi muito show rendimento
imediatamente com a reação dela mas sei
que tem muita gente que precisa sentir
isso disso o skate propicia nessa a
rodinha isso e essa integração que
acontece em nosso corpo que a gente não
consegue explicar com palavras a
sensação é única
e foi aí que nasceu skate a mesma
pergunta
é o que me anima é poder saber que o
skate tem um atravessamento tão
importante na minha vida que eu tenho a
minha profissão hoje ele conduziu o
encontro na adolescência ele tem que
conduzir em várias etapas me
proporcionando que vem proporcionando
influentes hoje queixa é ele está na
roupa que eu visto ele está na música
que eu escuto etapa meu trabalho
pessoas com deficiência ea gente entende
que a língua como skate trouxe essa
transformação pra gente vem se
transformando
por que não a gente pode contribuir para
pessoas que a gente atende pessoas que
têm algum tipo de deficiência que a
vitória é inimaginável a pessoa está ali
participando e tendo o mais importante
no skate essas oportunidades de vivência
a gente entende que o deficiente não é
um presente poder
ele é uma oportunidade que está ali de
animais ali para ser um facilitador
dessa oportunidade de ele ter essa
experiência de como o transformador é
quem diz cid é a melhor maneira de
explicar a como é transformador isso
como isso pode ter uma potência na vida
lado a pessoa falava 'não não não'
e aí na segunda terceira ou se matavam
sim sim eu quero fazer não vamos lá
daqui a pouco ele esse singelo sim daqui
a pouco que saiu o skate é um dia ela
vai comandar a noite
esse vídeo vai passando e calar a moeda
da bolinha
eu tô indo pegar uma coisa senão tomar
amanda foi o segurou pelo braço eu
preciso falar contigo eu bato bem ela eu
sou abordada a bolinha ea gente estava
encantado que recebeu o projeto
beneficente legal ela não está muito
feliz porque o irmão dela ter essa faixa
etária que ela é ex petista e ele viu o
vídeo ficou muito feliz
ocorre que botar 400 skate desde que ela
era expedida a gente ouviu que o livro
coisa como eu escrevo olhos e de onde
você está chegando
não é na vivência ele porque a gente
sabe que é divertido e sabe aonde quando
bate lá a família do irmão que eles não
tinham uma conexão que não se falava mas
quem faz essa via de acesso e transforma
toda uma dinâmica familiar estão tava
com ele
então isso é uma mudança que a gente
perde não é o nosso know ali sabe que
negativas não sabe que perdeu 14 de
novembro
mas quando bate lá ea gente nem tem mais
o controle é isso que temos que manter
isso com a gente pela gente tá aqui
falando para você ter uma idéia eu
imaginava na rede coletora de pé
obrigado
[Música]